all right here we go today's topic
I love Jonathan Majors there was
there was white girlfriend and when
internet
to me and he was in Sweden somewhere
with a blonde hair
white woman I don't celebrate that I'm
not gonna celebrate the children that
they have oh my God it doesn't make me
be like yes like you know some people
together you're like I love them
together that's how we all got here a
white woman and a black man help me
through this I don't have a logical
answer would I get agitated about is
because it's it's commercially trendy
for people to be in interracial
relationships it's become a presentation
of diluted Blackness like why aren't you
happy to see like all these mixed
families and Cheerios commercials no
because the storytelling is not our it's
not a mixed Story the storytelling is
this is what's digestible for white
people I don't mind seeing black women
with white men it gets even more
hold on
you know what makes us even funnier what
they're all mixed children yeah
yeah
that's actually amazing bruv you looking
like you
yo a mixed children but that's what she
did that's what she said that's what she
said that's the reason why that's when
she's yeah but I I didn't think about it
until I like look at it like wait
they're all mixed they're all mixed all
of them likes him sarcastic I'm like
well
okay it's funny that this is coming from
mixed women yeah but the thing the thing
as well as that there's a that's that
sentiment that they're okay with black
man being with white women and not okay
with black woman and being a white man
I've heard black men say that what that
that is what she said that it's weird
scene yeah that he has a problem
whenever we see like a black woman with
a white man he has defense some type of
win I'm like man you're a weirdo
you're a weirdo you're a whole that's
weird though
you go out with a white girl yeah but
that's okay but the but she can't go out
with
you're a weirdo if you're okay with one
not okay with the other
when we talk about man win like just
like you said you're weirdo you're
[ __ ] weirdo yeah if you don't like to
see black man or weird or white woman
and you're a mix kid you're [ __ ]
weirdo is that self-hate
you're a weirdo I think you got issues I
think there's some mixed kids who have
like an identity crisis yeah and sort of
feel like they belong sometimes they go
the extra mile that's why you've seen a
lot of like Civil Rights Movement even
though it makes people like such a small
minority you see them at a lot of the
Forefront of a lot of [ __ ] just because
it feels like they're over compensating
sometimes no no I'm really black bro
you're gonna know this bro bro we put
out a video it will happen and a girl
was a hitting on her on her white
conservative father
she was mixed oh yeah yeah she was comp
yeah her billionaire why conservative
she walked that [ __ ] back too after she
got all that backlash the thing after
talking with a lot of having a lot of
discussion with mixed kids and stuff
like that like they tell me they tell me
that it's part of like them growing up
one girl that I know was like on my back
about like
having a a white girlfriend and it was
on my back about that [ __ ] and I was
like but you light skin
that means it's somehow somewhere along
the way yeah no my mama black and I saw
her mama mom light skin hmm
maybe mean that from generation to
generation y'all only hang out with
house [ __ ]
but at some point something happened to
one of your black and sisters is that
where they Hate's from I don't know she
won't celebrate you
you're not you're not you're not getting
celebrated oh no no I'm not good your
kids they not when we celebrate no like
I wanted to have a celebration who are
you talking about she thought was she
talking about thrill some black famous
person is a little white woman in Sweden
I'm not gonna celebrate that person then
don't just don't don't don't you know
you know the weird thing is like but you
shouldn't be celebrated either then
happy birthday YouTube no stop
celebrating [ __ ]
the weird thing with with Blackness is
like it gets gatekeeps a lot for example
you're black until you say something
they don't like yeah you know what I
mean like if you parody what they say
like yes I'm not African brother blah
blah blah you see him it's because you
African and that's why or if you grew up
in the suburbs oh it's because you away
from the hood for too long or if you
talk with a certain accent it's like oh
you trying to be white oh you lived in
Montana there's not enough things but
that's why you talk the way that you
talk oh uh you did what you went away
for a few years seems you forgot your
Blackness while you were gone
um
and so there's all kinds of ways you
dating a white woman huh you're not
black right there's all kinds of ways
that folks get gig kept out of like any
kind of Heritage or cultural group or
whatever it might be and so it's
interesting at the drop of the time it's
like you are until you make one decision
they don't like and then it's like no
you're not anymore right it's one of
those things that
makes you question over time like what
does it really mean to be black yeah how
do you even get admission to the group
when is that mission even constant and
who really gets to decide and is it
really that much of a community it's not
monolithic you know what I'm saying it's
not the same across all boards so what
really ties all these people to bka and
the truth is there's not really much we
kind of understand it but it's very
nebulous it's amorphous it doesn't have
a shape or consistency it's this thing
that we've kind of linked to people over
but if you here's the thing if you went
up to most black folks you asked them
like what how are you black they're
gonna have different responses uh right
they're gonna happen what does it mean
part of you but everyone's gonna have a
bit of a different thing they'll have
different reasons so it's a very
difficult thing to own and to feel like
all right I get it and so when I hear
this speech this just feels like some
people want to be part of the in-group
and they're finding the reasons why
you're not part of the in-group oh you
dated a white one it's like well [ __ ]
you're mixed you why do you get to be
part of it and I like man it was really
like like how does that even make sense
now that I I subscribe to that
person gonna be the one to tell a black
person that they're like lesser than or
whatever it might be it's like you're
not gonna celebrate and say [ __ ] who
are you you you yeah you're like you get
what I'm saying you are not celebrated
the very thing that led to your
existence huh what are you talking about
it's like you would be often poof
vanished like Houdini if my black man
wasn't doing it so why do you have us
it's so weird and so honestly over time
my opinion on this like a lot of these
discussions has gone to the back you
know what I think now
amen
that's what I think
I'm like okay whatever you know sure
okay whatever you want what yeah
whatever you want but what do you want
that's really what that's really comes
that word it comes down to and I told
you my position about that a lot of
times right because of what I what what
will happen when I go out and stuff yeah
yay
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's the thing so yeah you know how
yeah
I get I got the backlash and stuff like
that like even when I go out even before
this YouTube thing and stuff like that
oh yo there's a whole blogs about us
because black woman oh yeah flower or
something I don't remember what the name
of that blog is oh my God it don't
matter how many white women I slap dude
they just don't believe me
but at some point after all this what
can you say you know I'm not trying to
like change anybody's opinion no but not
only that that opinion is Goofy it is
it's goofy as [ __ ] but what is nothing
else I would expect
I won't expect nothing else from that
you know what I mean it's like whatever
that's goofy I won't thought everything
that they said I think what they said
about like makes people being like
commercially viable is very true like
sometimes you know like the black people
they cast are like people with
eurocentric features rather than people
were like real black teachers
traditionally speaking so there's
definitely an element to that that I
think Rings true but it's just
interesting hearing them talk about an
individual in his choice of who he dates
and be like I'm not going to celebrate
that but I'll celebrate black women who
date out it's like yeah cause you got it
Queen yay get your bag if these ain't
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm not gonna go
get with white woman get you a rich
white man get you
I actually want to know from the black
man who are watching or just the black
folks do you guys not feel tired of this
conversation do you feel like it's one
that's still really important to have
like should we be deciding who we
celebrate or who we don't which I'm I
mean I'm not gonna lie it's kind of
cringe but to me that's my opinion I
don't want to color yours so let us know
in the comments below what you guys
think maybe we're off base I understand
what a hurt is I do understand where
it's from
like how miserable
miserable that's not Petty that's
miserable do you got to be
that whenever someone is celebrated
you're gonna turn around and the first
thing you do is Google search and see if
they if their wife is white and if there
is oh 20 fingers
Twitter fingers